all right we're going to begin this hour
with a powerful story a story about
overcoming obstacles and it's by our
lead National correspondent David begno
David met a teenager who has an
incredibly severe case of Tourette
Syndrome we're talking about ticks so
bad so intense that sometimes this
teenager felt like he was choking and by
the way it's a story that's personal for
David if you don't recall he himself was
diagnosed with Tourette Syndrome at age
six and so what David did in this case
is he followed along this 17 year old
from Pennsylvania as the child went
along what had a radical treatment we're
gonna see how he's doing now
how are you feeling
as he prepared for brain surgery
seventeen-year-old Callum de cuevedo
hoped for a chance at a normal life
a life that would overcome the grip
Tourette's Syndrome has had on him
there's no brain like calyps so he is
going to be a unique Challenge and
designing his trajectories will be
different from any other patient his
surgeon Dr Ted panov at Mount Sinai West
which is a hospital in New York City
told him that inserting wires into his
brain connected to a neurostimulator
under his collarbone where his last best
hope of reducing or even eliminating the
involuntary movements and Ticking sounds
tourettes has caused him to make we
scrub in the morning this surgical
procedure has successfully helped people
with Parkinson's disease but it has yet
to be approved by the FDA to treat
Tourette's syndrome calum's condition
became uncontrollable three years ago at
a high school track meet he was 14 years
old then you picked him up at the track
field and what was happening then he
just got in the car and he was down and
I said you know what's wrong he was
really excited about the track meet so
and he said I don't know can't breathe
Don de cuevado is callum's mom maybe
you're coming down with something you
know maybe you're getting a cold so the
next day he sent him off to school in
the nurse calls and says listen he
really is struggling to breathe so every
day that week the nurse called and said
something's not right but nobody knew it
was Tourette nobody knew it was a tick I
mean we went to an ENT and they said
well there's something called vocal cord
dysfunction and they sent us to a speech
therapist he said you know this is
beyond my expertise and he sent us to
Children's Hospital of Philadelphia how
many doctors did you see we estimate a
little over 30. 30 doctors yeah over
seven months before anybody diagnosed
him with Tourette Syndrome the worst
episodes led to frequent visits to the
emergency room
there are videos you experience ticks of
screaming cursing hitting yourself in
the head a lot of head-jerking face
scrunching grunting I know there were
these nights where one two three in the
morning he would just be up screaming
screaming
that's why we were videotaping it for
the doctors and just took a long time
for anybody to come to a conclusion did
it feel hopeless to you yeah after even
after I got diagnosed I struggled with
mental health and I actually tried to
kill myself at one point it's really
hard to give a kid this age who's really
looking forward to doing things in life
and you're sitting as a parent saying I
don't know if you can
how Callum got to be one of the few
people with Tourette's eligible for the
surgery was every bit a tribute to his
parents persistence to get help and to
get the insurance company on board and
it was a tribute to Dr juhi Jimenez
Shahid a neurologist and leading expert
on Tourette's at New York's Mount Sinai
West
you're very welcome take care now it's
not unusual for Tourette's to go
undiagnosed but after visiting 30
different doctors Mount Sinai offered a
promising treatment Callum is one of the
few folks to whom extra treatment is
needed a lot of people out there are
able to cover up for their ticks and are
able to deal with it but unfortunately
him as bright as he is it's really
stopping his life to make sure they
settle the procedure Dr panoff performed
back in December involved drilling two
small holes into callum's skull to
insert the tiny wires into his brain
guiding the surgeons was an MRI scanner
providing real-time images of the brain
to help find where the brain could be
most receptive for successful treatment
Calum will be the first one at our
Center on our scanner this is the first
time journalists were allowed to observe
and record the procedure the brain is
smarter than anything that we can ever
imagine and the brain is able to get
this help from this device and start
learning together with the device so
months after months KLM can show
Improvement callum's condition did not
show an immediate Improvement and it
wasn't expected to over the holidays his
skull had to heal her first then the
Staples needed to be removed all right
so we'll start with this guy here now
each one of these is going to be like a
tiny little Sting with that done all
right ready yep okay here we go Dr juhi
Jimenez Shahed slowly started the
neurostimulator that would send a
current to callum's head The Hope was he
would become calmer and gain some
control so kind of bit by bit we're
going to kind of ramp this up okay and
you tell me if that intensifies or if
you start noticing anything else yeah I
feel a lot more relaxed it's pretty
immediate huh yeah for the next hour and
a half the doctor adjusted the levels
and there was already reason for
optimism how about now I just feel like
this is the best I felt in a long time
now watch what happens when she turns
off the stimulators I'm going to go down
to zero okay so you tell me what changes
when we do that
what's happening there my like my ear
just came back for like my simple like
ticks
my toes are going crazy right now so
you're definitely feeling like you have
to do it now with the stimulator
attached to the left side turned off his
ticks came back then when she increased
the level of stimulation to the right
side he got more relaxed so that's The
Sweet Spot then he was ready to control
the device himself so you're going to
open up the app then it says your
therapy is on right so that's how easy
it is to do anything with it okay okay
the procedure and callum's initial
response were a success let's get to the
good part yes it is now working in your
head it's turned on yes it is how do you
feel I just feel very relaxed I don't
think I ever realized since I was 13
since like that breathing started how
like
um even like my muscles were always like
just very like contracted and like I was
always very stiff I think the biggest
thing today was when I had my hands out
like this and like the one side was
trembling and the other side wasn't no
neither one yeah now neither one is
trembling as bad as they were I have to
tell you I
in the brief time I've known you I've
noticed how stiff it makes you
you seem
at ease I definitely am I feel more
relaxed now like it's nice that I don't
have to be moving constantly to keep
myself distracted or to stop the ticks I
can sit at my house and watch TV without
worrying about screaming or hitting my
head or punching myself or anything like
that
I just want to smile just listening to
that Callum tells us that he believes
his ticks have been reduced 70 since
this device was implanted in his brain
boy David thank you for bringing us that
story it's so fascinating to watch it
happen in real time as you were showing
the difference that it was making for
Callum and kudos to his mom is dad and
him for going through that it was scary
just watching it anytime you see the
brain open that way that was very very
daunting to watch but the outcome is
fantastic
immense it's huge I mean you go from
talking less about your tics to more
about your dreams he's talking about
going back to school he's looking into
the future rather than looking down at
the ground I mean I I I've never seen
someone struggle as much as Callum did
and almost immediately I looked at him
and things just softened from head to
toe it was remarkable and what's it like
for you David because you know somewhat
what this young man feels what's it like
for you to see this happen
oh it warms my heart because I don't
struggle as much as he does but uh you
know we all have issues something we're
dealing with but my heart just pained
watching this young man sit at home and
um I just can't salute his parents
enough because everyone deserves a set
of parents I mean I could we thinking
about it everyone deserves a set of
parents like that young man has they are
the reason he is still alive today and
they are the reason he is now better
than ever yeah his parents and his
medical team I'll take two please thank
you David thank you beautiful story
David again amen David Beck now strikes
again